nothing harder than looking at our loved
ones and realizing they have opted out
of relationship with us
and you have to enter into a season of
grief otherwise you are choosing to let
those shoulds and those desires bury you
right and I think entering into grief is
letting go of what I hoped would happen
what I wanted to happen and just
accepting
this is what happened right and when you
can do that from that Ash is where you
build what comes next we feel like we've
lost trust you have we feel like they've
just abandoned us they did and you've
got to sit there and it's the worst and
it's uncomfortable and it's lonely and
it's from that Ash that the soil is is
fertile so you can start you got to find
a gang people that aren't afraid to try
you're gonna have to get a community in
a tribe that is not one that you're
attached to by Blood but that you choose
right that's the that's the work ahead
of you